PAUL RILEY: Good afternoon.
My name is Paul Riley, and
I'm a senior in the politics
department here at
Princeton University.
And today, on this
beautiful Friday afternoon,
I'm happy to be at
HireTigers Meetup,
a new alternative
career fair put
on by the Office
of Career services.
Hire Tigers Meet Up is truly
an alternative career fair.
When you're walking
throughout the tent,
you can see companies from
a broad array of industries.
So you have so many
opportunities for students
to really challenge
and reimagine
what it means to have a
career outside of Princeton.
PULIN SANGHVI:
Today's event turned
on its head many
of the assumptions
underlying the traditional
job fair model.
We held it outdoors in
an informal setting.
And we involved alumni
and employers in new ways.
And there was a sense of genuine
exploration and serendipitous
conversations happening
all around us.
PAUL RILEY: There
were bistro tables
where you could walk
up to alums and really
learn about their career
path, how they ended up
where they did.
You can see how they took
the unconventional roots.
And that's really
encouraging for someone
like me, who as a senior doesn't
have everything figured out.
PULIN SANGHVI: The
event was designed
from the ground up with deep
input from the students.
They helped us challenge
the assumptions
of the traditional
job fair model.
The panel discussions brought
out tremendous insights
on things like whether
your major is connected
to what your career
opportunities will be.
DANIEL EDWARDS: Being
a religion major,
I probably have a major
that most people won't
have when I'm applying for jobs.
What type of specific things
would you say you look for?
BLAIR LABATT: We
all know that you
don't have to be a theologian
if you major in religion.
You don't have to be a book
editor if you major in English.
DUSTIN DAVIDSON: I can
kind of separate myself
as showing my sense of
curiosity, my willingness
to follow my passion, as opposed
to what I'm supposed to do.
JAKE ROBERTSON: I was
wondering if you guys have
any opinions on
starting somewhere else?
I'm from Chicago.
PAUL BOGAEV: Yes.
Chicago is the first-- the
theater scene is great there.
BARBARA SCHOTTENFELD: If you're
in love with the process,
as David said, you
really can't fail.
Because if the show doesn't
go on to the next step or et
cetera, at least you've
had that experience.
If you work on something
for the wrong reasons
and it doesn't work,
then what do you have?
ROBERT N SANDBERG: That's
also about it being a career.
If that's the reason that you do
this because you love doing it.
PULIN SANGHVI: The
organization's told us
that they felt more
visible and able
to engage in better
conversations.
The alumni told us that
this was a great venue
to share their journey and
their stories with the students.
And the students told us that
this was a great and informal
way to make connections
and personally explore
what meaningful
work means to them.
I think what made
this event so special
was the way that all of us--
students, alumni, employers,
and Career Services-- came
together as one community
to create something
extraordinary for the student
experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]